when we think about what's difficult in
the modern world
we're liable to think about meal times
how seldom they now take place
communally
how rare it is for whole families to
gather how much
technology can intrude in paintings of
communal meals from the olden days
we can appreciate how all ages used to
come together
around one table and how welcoming the
atmosphere seems to have been
even the family horse might have been
invited to join in
the modern condition appears so bleak by
comparison
rather than a family around the hearth
the emblematic images of a single person
with a tray on their knees
in front of the television it was the
swanson corporation
originally a poultry producer in omaha
nebraska
that launched the frozen tv dinner in
1954 the same year coloured television
was introduced in the u.s
it is a short distance in time but a
long way in spirit
from norman rockwell's laughter-filled
family thanksgiving celebration
to swanson's industrially produced
turkey meal for one
the modern world is surely a lonelier
place than the one that preceded it
the question is why it isn't ultimately
technology that has made us lonely it's
an identifiable set of
ideas we've rendered ourselves lonely
first and foremost because of certain
stories
we've started to tell about what
loneliness means
most eras before our own knew that
solitude did not per se
have to be a sign of wretchedness in the
4th century
the greatest saint of early christianity
saint anthony
was said to have spent more than 40
years by himself
in egypt's western desert not saying a
word eating only bread and salt
and communing with god so impressed with
some with anthony's life
they came to join him in the desert and
became collectively known as the desert
fathers
their philosophy of solitary piety would
go on to have a decisive influence
on the founding of monasteries at the
height of monasticism in the middle ages
a million people across europe and north
africa
chose to forego the bustle of family in
order to dwell
in some of the most rugged and remote
terrain in the world
in silent contemplation of god
however in the wake of the reformation
and the destruction of the monasteries
solitary piety began to lose its
prestige
and receded as a practical option those
who had previously lived alone at the
tops of mountains
were now encouraged to serve god by
remaining in the community
finding a spouse and starting a family
to this newly social religious impetus
was added the influence of
romanticism a movement of ideas that
with different ends in view
similarly encourage people to give up on
commitments to their own company
for the romantics happiness lay in
identifying
one exceptional soulmate to whom what
could surrender one's independence
and with whom one might fuse mind and
body
the romantic movement turned solitude
from a respectable choice
to evidence of pathology
when the beatles released eleanor rigby
in 1966
the song that more than any other
defined what loneliness meant for the
modern age it was at once clear
why elena was a pitiful figure the
famous face that she kept in a jar by
the door
had been intended for an enchanting
partner that
like all single people she must surely
have longed to find
only with romantic love could there be a
decent life
so ran the philosophy of the song of all
the beatles works and in fact
of pretty much every pop song ever
written
failed to fall completely in love and
romanticism warned
one would soon enough be picking up rice
in the church where a wedding had been
or rivalling for strangeness the very
odd father mackenzie
around whom there seemed to be so little
of the glamour that had once attended
the desert fathers the modern world
not only made it mandatory to have a
partner it's also made it feel essential
to have a vibrant gang of friends and to
enjoy seeing them
regularly at parties an empty diary has
become an
emblem of deformity but there is not the
slightest admission
that it might all things considered be a
bit of a curious thing to stand in a
crowded room
full of status panicked often socially
anxious people
every one of them terrified of honesty
or failure
in 1921 carl jung in his book
psychological types
introduced the terms extroverted and
introverted to divide humanity
the former referred to a sort of person
who could best realize their potential
in the company of others the latter were
those who needed to move away from
crowds
in order to regain their integrity
everyone possesses
both mechanisms wrote jung but it was
evident where the spirit
of the modern age has resided
it has been the achievement of a few
often ignored artists of the modern
period
to make a case for introversion to try
to coat
solitude in glamour in a painting by the
german artist caspar david friedrich
we're invited to trust that the lonely
figure in the landscape
is privy to insights that might be lost
in the crowd
down in the lowlands the man is needed
to travel up to the mountains
in order to put the bluster and envy of
humans in perspective
we should dare to follow him in his
trajectory
separated by many decades gwen john's
young woman
doesn't seem to belong to an official
religion but if there was one dedicated
to the appreciation of solitude
then she would be one of its saintly and
legendary figures
her expression kind gentle melancholy
is an advertisement for all that the
modern world has neglected
in its promotion of active cheery lives
isolation isn't a particular curse
it's just where good people tend to end
up
we should dare to believe that we are in
solitude not because we are mentally ill
but because we are noble of spirit we
don't hate company
it's just that we would prefer to stay
home rather than accept the counterfeit
tokens of community
that are too often on offer the way to
make people feel less alone
isn't to pull them out of their musings
in the forest or in the diner
in the library or the desert and force
them to go bowling
it's to reassure them that being alone
is no sign of failure
to lessen modernity's crisis of
loneliness we need for solitude to be
rehabilitated
and for singlehood to regain its dignity
there is nothing catastrophic about
eating dinner
many dinners on our own those swanson tv
dinners
might have been capable of improvement
but it is ultimately
far better to be eating a basic meal in
peace
than to be in a ballroom surrounded by
full smiles and oppressive judgments
when we do so we aren't in fact on our
own at all
we are as the modern world fails to
remind us
dining with some of the finest most
elevated
spirits who have ever lived we are
though ostensibly by ourselves
in the very best company
one of the trickiest tasks we ever have
to face
is that of working out who we really are
this book is designed to help us create
a psychological portrait of ourselves
with the use of some unusual oblique
entertaining and playful prompts
click the link on screen now to find out
more